>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
AFTER WEEKS OF HYPE AND
INNUENDO AND THREATS AND A
LOT OF HYSTERICS, WE FINALLY
HAVE THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE MEMO IN HAND
IT, WHAT'S IN IT, WHAT IT
MEANS, WHAT IT TELLS US
ABOUT HOW OUR LEADERS GOVERN
VIEWER YOU KNOW WE RARELY
WE THINK THIS IS WORTH IT.
THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH LYING
ABOUT THIS MEMO BIPARTISANS
IN CONGRESS AND HIGH HYENAS
IN THE PRESS.
LESSONS ARE AT RISK OF BEING
DROWNED OUT AND LOST.
TRUTH IS THE ANTIDOTE TO
THAT.
WHAT DOES THE MEMO ACTUALLY
SAY?
IT TURNS OUT IT'S NOT
PRIMARILY ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
CAMPAIGN VOLUNTEER CALLED
CARTER PAGE WHO, BACK IN
2016, WAS IDENTIFIED BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AS A
SECRET AGENT OF THE PUTIN
GOVERNMENT.
FOUR TIMES FBI OFFICIALS
WENT TO A FEDERAL
SURVEILLANCE COURT AND
ARGUED THEY HAD PROBABLE
CAUSE TO BELIEVE THAT CARTER
PAGE WAS WORKING WITH
RUSSIAN SPIES.
HE WAS AN AGENT OF A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
THREE TIMES THE FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY PERSONALLY
SIGNED OFF ON THIS CLAIM.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW
MCCABE AND DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN PUT
THEIR NAMES TO IT AS WELL.
SO WHY WERE ALL OF THESE
OFFICIALS SO CERTAIN THAT
PAGE, WHO WAS A NAVAL
ACADEMY GRADUATE WHO HAS NO
CRIMINAL RECORD, WAS
BETRAYING HIS COUNTRY?
BECAUSE, WE NOW KNOW, THEY
WERE RELYING ON THE TRUMP
OPPOSITION RESEARCH DUMP
PAID FOR BY THE RNC AND THE
HILLARY CAMPAIGN AND
COMPILED BY A BRITISH SPY
NAMED CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THE TRUMP DOSSIER MADE
SPYING ON CARTER PAGE
POSSIBLE.
HOW ARE WE SURE OF THAT?
BECAUSE ANDREW McCABE OF
THE FBI SAID SO BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS UNDER OATH TO
CONGRESS JUST THIS PAST
DECEMBER.
NOW, DEMOCRATS ARE NOW
FURIOUSLY DENYING THAT IN
RAH NONE MUST LEAKS TO
SYMPATHETIC REPORTERS BUT
IT'S OBVIOUSLY TRUE.
IN A MINUTE WE WILL TALK TO
A MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHO WAS
IN THE ROOM WHEN MCCABE SAID
EVIDENCE THAT PAGE WAS A
RUSSIAN SPY WHY DID THEY
LEAD WITH IT?
THE TRUMP DOSSIER ALLOWED
OUR GOVERNMENT TO SPY ON
CARTER PAGE.
THAT IS NOT A TALKING POINT.
IT IS A FACT.
GIVEN THAT IT IS A FACT, IT
IS REMARKABLE TO LEARN THAT
THE FBI KNEW AT THE TIME
THAT THE DOSSIER WAS
UNRELIABLE.
PUT IT CHARITIABLY.
AN INDEPENDENT FBI UNIT
ONLY MINIMALLY CORROBORATED.
THE FBI ALSO KNEW THAT THE
DOSSIER'S AUTHOR,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS
UNINFLAMED PARTISAN WORKING
ON BEHALF OF POLITICAL
OPERATIVES TRYING TO WIN A
PRESIDENTIAL RACE YOU WILL
REMEMBER.
STEELE TOLD BRUCE OHR THAT
HE WAS QUOTE, DESPERATE THAT
DONALD TRUMP NOT GET ELECTED
AND WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT HIM
NOT BEING PRESIDENT.
GOOD FAITH TREAT THE TRUMP
DOSSIER AS PACKET.
YET THAT IS HOW THE FBI
PRESENTED IT TO THE FISA
COURT WHEN THEY ASKED TO BY
ON CARTER PAGE.
THEY NEVER MENTIONED ANY OF
THE FACTS WE JUST GAVE YOU,
THEY HID THEM.
THAT IS LYING.
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY TO
DESCRIBE IT THEY HAVE BEEN
BUSTED LYING, BUT THEY WON'T
ADMIT IT FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
JIM COMEY TOOK TO TWITTER
TODAY NOT TO APOLOGIZE FOR
ANY OF THIS OR EVEN ADDRESS
THE FACTS THE MEMO RAISED
BUT TO MOCK THE RELEASE OF
THE MEMO LIKE THE INSPIRING
MSNBC CONTRIBUTOR HE
APPARENTLY IS DISHONEST AND
MISLEADING, HE SAID, HE
DIDN'T BOTHER TO EXPLAIN HOW
IT WAS DISHONEST AND
MISLEADING.
OF COURSE, HE DIDN'T.
COMEY, WHO LEAKED HIS NOTES
ON PRIVATE MEETINGS WITH THE
PRESIDENT IN A PETTY REVENGE
PALE SOMEHOW FOR CONGRESS TO
CARRY OUT ITS CONSTITUTIONAL
DUTIES OF OVERSIGHT OF THE
FBI.
COMEY APPARENTLY CONFUSED
THE FBI AS FOURTH BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT NOT SUBJECT TO
THE OTHER THREE.
SUDDENLY A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON SEEM TO AGREE
WITH THAT THE CURRENT FBI
DIRECTOR, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
ONE THAT TRUMP CHOSE,
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, HE
APPARENTLY ARGUED THAT THE
NAMES OF FBI OFFICIALS IN
THE MEMO OUGHT TO BE
REDACTED, HIDDEN FROM PUBLIC
VIEW.
WHY?
HOW EXACTLY WOULD THAT SERVE
PUBLIC INTEREST TO PROTECT
THE FBI.
AND AS ALWAYS, THAT WAS THE
POINT.
ALL OF THIS SHOULD MAKE YOU
NERVOUS.
THE DISHONESTY MIXED WITH
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS.
EVEN BELIEVED JUST FOR A
MOMENT, EVEN, THAT CARTER
THEY CLEARLY DON'T BELIEVE
THAT NOW.
IF THEY DID, PAGE WOULD BE
IN HANDCUFFS.
YET, HE IS STILL A FREE MAN.
THOUGH HIS CIVIL LIBERTIES
HAVE BEEN VIOLATED AND HIS
DEMOCRATS COULD NOT CARE
LESS.
THEY ARE STILL PREPRETENDING
THAT CARTER PAGE HURT THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY KNOW THAT'S A LIE.
PAGE HIMSELF WHAT HAPPENS TO
HIM IN THE FUTURE IS ALL
IRRELEVANT TO HIM.
IF HE CAN BE USED TO DESTROY
A PRESIDENT THEY HATE, THEY
ARE HAPPY TO USE HIM EVEN IF
HE IS CRUSHED IN THE
PROCESS.
AND THAT MAYBE THE REAL
LESSON OF THIS MEMO AND THE
REASON WE ARE SPENDS AN HOUR
ON IT TONIGHT.
10 YEARS AGO DONALD TRUMP
WILL BE GONE AND DEMOCRATS
WILL PRETEND THEY ONCE
FEARED RUSSIA.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY ALSO
REMAIN AS LONG AS THIS
COUNTRY STAYS INTACT AND WE
HAVE GOT TO TRUST THEM.
WE GIVE INCREDIBLE POWERS,
AWESOME POWERS, INCLUDING
THE POWER TO TAKE HUMAN
LIFE, THE MOST BASIC OF ALL.
WE ASK THEM TO OPERATE WITH
INTEGRITY, TO PROVE TO US
THAT THEY HAVEN'T BECOME
TOOLS OF POLITICAL REGIME
BECAUSE ALWAYS AND